uh bar can you like sh he's in the
marathon right now dude he's on the 13th
mile he's at the halfway point you have
those abs before this
[Music]
FL all right there's a there's a really
cool company called Fortress they make
gun safes do you know about them oh
Fortress no yeah they make awesome gun
safes that uh uh it uses biometric it
unlock oh it's like a new school Gun
Company okay do you have any of the
fingerprint based safes for I have three
of them oh you do oh those are cool and
it like works you just go and it opens
up it's I have that but then I I just
stick to the code cuz it's uh cuz in an
emergency you have to like you know you
want to it's harder to like scan the
whole finger so I feel like the the
number is more reliable but it has about
is it pretty exact where like uh if
you're off a little bit it's not going
to like open the safe it's like if
you're like shaky and some crazy [__]
happens I don't think the technology is
is that good yeah oh I don't know if
it's uh why'd you buy it well that's why
that's why it has a number the whole
hand it's just a couple fingers that
okay wait hold on it has a a code how
long is a code it could be like three
digits four digits oh I was going to say
cuz if you got a [__] 16
digits click all the photos with
bicycles is said a bicycle's a part of a
bicycle I don't know if I I don't you're
[__] dead dude what about this you oh
you got one of these oh R SC [__] sick
so all they've they've been on the
market for a while these these gun safes
but then they recently had to recall
61,000 safes because there were 39 other
cases where people came forward about
the safe opening up with someone else's
fingerprint or just randomly yeah that's
why I don't try the I don't trust the
biometric stuff just yet because there
it is faulty and also I think it was
saying like um um 61,000 yeah like 90 I
think like it's because your fingerprint
is so intricate a lot of them are set
just to be able to scan 75% of it in all
open but then you also like let's say
you gain weight and your fingers are
different or or if it's cold is it going
to you know it's like it's for all the
fatties out there right Bart yeah yeah
yeah you get yeah it's just it's not
reliable I think I think it takes too
long you go in it goes
beep like it's like 2 3 seconds oh yeah
there a situation where uh so even
though there was those cases of people
like saying that they're safe open there
was one particular case where a
12-year-old kid was able to open the
safe what and he took the gun out and
shot himself
[__] and so they're trying to figure out
now how he that's just a very ambitious
[__] 13 in September I don't know bar
I would shoot myself I think I feel like
I would be like I probably would have
too yeah seriously but it's like how
that's like [__]
breaking into a bank and stealing all
the money in the vault and then losing
all of it the next day it's just like
that's so stupid but so smart it's like
you got the prize what are we going to
do with the prize the gun is the prize
right so I guess they're trying to
figure out how he did it they're saying
I think there's a response from the
company that saying it might be that it
was on open mode oh the [__] is that
that's a good mode to have on I
say perfect mode yeah yeah if you're
going to want have a mode this safe has
open mode open and the gun was on shoot
yourself
mode they're just saying it's good
Biometrics cuz it passes down
genetically the guy's kid same same
blood The Perfect Storm man go right
back I'm like do we share fingerprints
with our parents yeah I the same [__]
punches into your blood can your [__]
dog go like that and opens it too we
should try we should try putting a dog
Paul and the dog just [__] running
around with the gun so I guess it's like
a maybe that's like the when you're
programming it you know like when you go
to hotel and the safe in the hotel is on
open mode like you use it I don't use
that do you say no I've never seen
that's [__] crazy it seems kind of
weird because you know that they have
like a master key or something so why
would what's the yeah but that's that's
the whole locked in that's a I like
analog [__] man analog it works the best
just when it's not tooo like even with
when it comes to like AC or like
whatever it's like click click click
click versus like some crazy digital
[__] like there's so much digital stuff
it's just you could just uh break down
like in helicopters do they have [__]
thumb print things they don't have thumb
print things yeah why would they have
that right everything's analog in a
helicopter right so it's like if you're
up there and something breaks down you
need to fix it you need a thumb just
things that are just physically and it's
like it's not working it's not and
you're just crashing have you seen
there's a there was a viral video of
this uh woman that was at the bank and I
guess she had opened her door to use the
uh drive up ATM yeah and like she
positioned her car incorrectly where
like the door was open where like if she
were to back up the door would hit the
ATM machine but she couldn't go forward
because you can't start the car and put
it in gear when the doors open see but
she couldn't close the door oh cuz
there's too much like
automatic so it's blocking her from
moving but she's like all right well
then I'm stuck here so what did she do
turn off the car no her husband had to
come and like uh they they did some
weird thing to like get the door to shut
but um I think he like had to like super
push it but it wouldn't go in neutral at
first either because of the you know the
lock out that happened to my uh my
girl's car too she a Jeep in the little
sensors and I got stuck I couldn't go
forward cuz I parked my car it's hard to
explain but I had to like we had to move
the cars around and I did it myself cuz
she was like I'm going to take it's
going to take me a while so I'll do it
myself so I parked her car then I parked
mines but I parked mine a little close
and I guess behind her was like grass
that was hit in the sensor oh [__] so
the sensor wouldn't let me reverse and
it wouldn't let me go for so I was like
stuck and I'm like where the [__] do I
get out so you had to go get a lawn
mower that's the only way you can't turn
off the sensor all the grass you can't
no it can't off the sensor so then I had
to like cut the grass not a lot more but
I cut it with my hand but I was like
imagine if I didn't have that if it was
like something that I couldn't remove I
would have been I would have been [__]
were you in the backyard like this you
[__] [__] [__] oh yeah I was
like when I get mad at cousin
Spanish I don't my dad I don't know what
it is and then um yeah so I was able to
reverse was like imagine getting stuck
and that's that's that's kind of faulty
isn't it like that's really annoying I
don't know I think you guys are all
talking about very like really rare and
unique anomaly in but why even put
overall technology I think is cool
here's here's another here's another
rare that's too much technology here's
another rare unique anomaly case robot
been seeing this I've been seeing this
kind of a lot all so whenever there
there's these Street takeovers or
there's like riding or just shit's going
off in the street you always see a Tesla
that's stuck oh yeah yeah and then
people start [__] it up why is the
Tesla stuck I I don't know cuz I
legitimately asked like in the comments
I'm like yo anyone with a Tesla is there
a lockout that keeps you from gunning it
through
people cuz that's lame oh
[__] has sensors for like human
everywhere right there is something like
that right cuz when when you drive in a
Tesla on some of people's maps you see
like little people yeah cuz you always
see them like trying to get the [__] out
but they can't and they're just going
they're just jering all these kids
lamming on the roof they're just jerking
forward and then like people are just
smashing [__] how you stop a Tesla funny
that hella protects Tesla though yeah is
it [__] your brand Imaging and stuff
like that liabil the car getting [__]
up because like humans are being whacked
and it's like humans but if their car is
hitting people yeah especially at the
speeds that they they have that's true
you know what I mean sa guard that's
crazy that it won't it won't let you go
through it's like a a friend who never
breaks the rules [__] yeah yeah yeah
[__] that guy you know what I'm saying
that's kind of scary though if you think
about it like if it's you sure yeah yeah
like if someone's trying to like like
carjack you you got to like imag imagine
you're in a zombie you're in a zombie
apocalypse and you're in a [__] Tesla
you're [__] dead bro you can't run
over no zombies no no because the
cameras uh work differently on zombies
okay that's the new update I do like
automatic everything except for the
stuff that matters so like AC automatic
I don't want to [__] touch that Every
Day Blinds dead it yeah all that stuff
like [__] guns gun safe my car if I
need to [__] just book it I want to
be able to break any rule like imagine
later on the Tesla it won't even let you
drive on the wrong side of the road or
bust a you if there's Double Y yellow
like I want to be able to break any rule
anytime if I need to you know there's a
mode like break the ru R go Rogue or
something like that [__] it I'm doing it
goog Rog
mode what if what on your own brother
what you're on your own brother and then
[__] go what if they could control
your car turn it off or like like you're
just trying to like get out of state or
whatever and then they can control it
and make you yeah that's scary that's my
thing is like they could be able to
control it right yeah I think if they
could they also wouldn't make it obvious
that that's what's happening I think
they' be like oops your car broke down I
don't know what's happening to it but
the B right there only buy cars before
1995 really RoboCop cars your truck
before 1995 shut your mouth man shut up
shut up yeah yeah yeah that's why I got
16 guns and safes that only activate by
my voice this is like not you have a gun
without the safety take that [__] [__]
off this I know what I'm shooting this
is a different thing but it's still kind
of a tech related thing is those um
devices that like they'll these workout
guys will hook up to it and and it'll
just pulse and they'll go this is the
equivalent of 5,000 situps in oh yeah
yeah yeah you see the little Mach oh the
electric yeah those don't work that's
not a thing stimulators as you're eating
a [__] burger and like so every
stimul cuz I'll be like yeah you feel
that that's like you just did 10,000
setup it reminds me of those Electro
massage things where they just kind of
shock your muscles and you're doing this
it's like you're throbbing boner all
over that's just [__] you know what
I learned so I asked uh my physical
therapist I was like cuz you know
physical therapy hurts like [__] yeah
I'm like I'm a little [__] I don't want
to feel all this [__] all the time I'm
like what if one day I just get [__]
knocked out I lay on the table and you
just work all my knots out and what he
what he explained was your body only
heals when it wants to so if you're out
and I'm pressing and I'm manipulating on
you it's a what's One Direction it
actually won't heal it heals from me
going like this and your body resisting
me so that's why those things don't work
because it's an external Force flexing
your muscles not you flexing your
muscles
oh so you got go everything has so
everything has to come from you exactly
so they've done studies where like
people they don't even do a lap pull
down they just think about lap pull
Downs for like and they they they run a
a mental program and like 12 Weeks Later
their muscle mass actually grew from
their brain thinking about it so it has
to come from you this Mak like what is B
to like working out right
now dude I'm I'm going go on a marathon
next time I'm flying on an airplane I'm
just going to oh damn that's difficult
oh I got to
pee Oh water someone give you water uh
bar can you like sh he's in the marathon
right now dud he's on the 13th mile he's
at the halfway point you have those abs
before
like just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kiding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kiding news the number one one
foodcast in the
[Music]
world